because Jacque we already lost her
Whitaker yeah
don't want to see that yeah but man I
mean how many more years do you think
chakra is gonna fight he's 38 yeah he
beat the guy who was gonna get the title
shot right don't you think yeah oh no my
mom was for sure they were gonna fly
them to the fight to be a alternate but
here's the thing we put their hands up
there's [ __ ] ten minutes left I don't
understand hey where's what are they
doing I don't understand - if you don't
want to get the bonus do this kick to
the body their elbow knocked Korean
Zombie out oh my god that wasn't all the
coaches out it's so stupid baby just I'm
celebrating was insane flatlined him oh
my god zombie dumb he's still out the
doctor is calling the doctor over is it
fried nose dude that [ __ ] elbow fly
can we get a replay Jesus oh he's hurt
man as I ears hurt see how he got up and
he just winced in pain what do you what
did he hurt just coached out here with
this dude this is a one of the best not
get was that on the buzzer yes look at
this whoo book-burning elbow insane holy
mama I've never seen that sweet look
I've never ever seen the bang oh my god
oh my goodness what a [ __ ] Kay on a
beautiful bow creating oh my god oh my
god dude that was can we get the
cleanest clock at the back oh my god two
seconds so Tuesday be second suit and I
wonder what the scorecard we're going
into that that's a good question
I wish we were paying attention yeah
listen we watch the ko